[Musique]
la critique est émotionnellement limite
un terrain teinte
j'espérais que vous trouveriez quelque
chose qui puisse expliquer ce qui se
passe lequel est le mieux le 1 ou le
veut mieux pire pas de différence pas de
différence
j'ai bien envie de savoir ce que tu en
penses que la sobriété de l'upa bien
réussi père cité en plein alcoolisme
puristes
à cette époque c'est ce que j'ai dit
j'aurais jamais dû arrêter de boire
aucune originalité oh quel courage
[Musique]
je ne peux rien faire pour vous sauver
j'ai trouvé une perle qui a fait ça
hypnotique d'un voisin qui est décédé et
vous vous êtes servi il n'avait ni
famille ni amis je peux vous rendre
heureux
prodigieux il ya une telle demande
qu'ils sont tous prêts étranglé connaît
un artiste du nom de maîtrise non
nationaliste et pourtant on a tout le
monde
l'artiste a utilisé son sens pour créer
des rouges foncés
tout arrive de regarder cette peinture
t'as jamais rien remarqué de bizarre
elle est vivante
[Musique]
en faisant mes recherches sur 10 je me
suis aperçu que le dégoût de l'argent et
est présent dans toute son oeuvre
10 a passé 20 ans dans un institut
psychiatrique pour criminels
pathologique
tout est en lien avec les offres
un esprit qui émane d'elle
tout est entièrement liée à son art
j'ai l'absolue certitude qui est en
train de se passer quelque chose de
dingue
ici c'est un abattoir
vous êtes au courant que dix avaient
demandé à ce que son oeuvre soit
détruite
oh
décosse toutes ses toiles
book le livre lieu sûr
je ne peux rien faire pour vous sauver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gens passaient devant elle comme si
c'était une oeuvre
on a des milliers de vues sur instagram
m'ont pas des records